ドカーン
[音楽]
始めというわけで今日の実験 aiko の密室空間で行なっていきたいともうみんな
がコミュニティ雲という言葉をご存じだろうか
東京で行われるでかいコミックマーケットを略してコミケというイベントがあるんだ
なぁコミュニティってめちゃくちゃ人が多いですね雑誌の会議で人が多くて多くて
あまりに多すぎでもすっ
すごい読み終っちゃって本当に多くてそれだけたくさんニーズが来ると思いますとの
デッキが凄すぎて冬なのにですよ冬なのに汗とか蒸気と金子逃げ会場の上を見ると雲が
って言ってたらしいんですよこれを込め器具庫というこのコミュニティ久保のおかげで
私は一つ分かったことがある我々人間でウォッチ内で蜘蛛は作れてる今日はこの震災を
フェア乙
やってくもん食って済みするものはこちら加湿器もうこれあのコミケに来てる人と同じ
なんですが曇って度会でできるかというと水分が出てそれが個性送金は上に入って上の
方で冷やされて雲になるらしいんですよただコミケでも同じで人の熱気とか汗とかこう
上に一定で拭い何で上で冷却されて雲になったこれでなぜ同じ
原理家で出来るんです今全体量の貸し付けを準備しますこの後質疑を作る大量の水分を
保つを外させて垂直として上に生かせるそれを行え悪を使って冷たくしてもクーラーだ
してきますガンガン冷たくすると成長期が英訳されて僕の家の上にも空港
ないかと私は思ったわけですよそれでもさすがいうの中で空母が作れるかどうかよって
いうことをもうブライト
首ったけます面倒くさいんだよなんつー24個くらい準備しましたさすがにこんな
小さい部屋に課す次に14個人いないと思うんで比率的には小麦に近い空間を作れると
思うよね
ううーーあそぼ
多すぎて引いているサイトには24万か取得準備しました
国家は水上曲はがんばって出まくってこれをクーラー冷やしたら雲ができます間違い
ありません
ちょっとほど福ちゃんこんなと24この二木水を塗ってペンネームを接続し食べて
いこうと思います皆さんよねはーい
さあヘアノートは鈴慕17度というヘアの入学が進んでおります
今部屋は中なの早速加湿器を起動させているくっつきます
あってきたんですよ私はこれを待っていたあーこんな調子でどんどん歌詞付きローさん
に行きましょう paperkit
goo
いやーもう過失というよりきりだな霧の終わってないよね部屋の加湿が進んでおります
鯉のめっちゃくちゃなんて書いて決まりませんよんなって言っても過言ではないだろう
て下のほうは結構曇ってるんですけども上はまだ実はね曇ってはいません雲の発生はみ
られませんかしてキノコの蒸気時代なんかあったかくないんですよねことは当てとは
違うなっている
これが暗くすると綺麗な気がすんだよなぁ暗くします
me
ブーブーと思います
[音楽]
ブーブー
うんうん ian 29度ですそしてもう奪っても前が命が完全さあだもう
見えることですけどいざイメージで使っているかつてきもってきましたこれによりそう
に過失が触れるわけでしょ
入ってるけど部屋がすごいことになってきましたもうサーブ大ブームですやばいもう何
か冷たいものは全部水 t 2月くらいです
床戻りてんじゃんっていうかも
ただいま部屋なんだか25.9度出演とか99%ほぼ水です
あっはぁ
床が出るするねもうすごい部屋が基本冷たいものはで全部で結論してますねどっかお
菓子付き時代の今の水の部分もね結露してますね愛とだけで考える人はたくさん密集し
て東1時が汗かきまくって阿蘇来てむさ苦しい蝶タイにはできました
兵士が未だに上にクモはできておりませんでここでないテクも発生するよと言いますと
レイド
方にですねこの熱い蒸気を冷却するようにすればそのが原理的にはできるわけなんです
けどもなので映さ辛い名簿に書いて上に冷たい空気を集める増税があならず小路くんも
あると思うでは冷房付きまし入ってゆけで17度の冷房にしてきましたこのまま放置
するとこの汗っぽい臓器たちは上で果たして蜘蛛になる
どうでしょうかしましょう持ち oi 冷たい液が下に彼が言うに冷たい風の向きを
見るだけにしておりますなんかめっちゃ上に上がって来てねこれウマって言ってるです
あるとすごいよねー真ん中明らかねー
雲みたいな見栄ですよ
しかもなんですけどこれ意外とここらへんはそういう場合っての上に行けば行くほど
ですね
もう久保っとくなっておりますこれすなわち
実験性いっかー
[音楽]
何か僕のイメージだったら上にもくもくもくってこれに雲ができておーって感じだった
んですけども
部屋全体が雲
car
me
バッハ
どれくらいで戻るでも切ってみました知ったらどういう具合に戻るが
は次へカス取り切ったら一瞬で消えるああいう合図残ってるわふなんか下の方すごいで
もうめっちゃクリアだと思うんですよねしたの文化史できるすげー戻るんだなぁ
床もモードも別のリザだよもうやらんとこ